Well, We covered bilinear interpolation and nearest neighbor interpolation,
Um, Which obviously see a lot of use in any kind of imagery sampling.
But of course the one we all use now is Bicubic, and I kinda left that one hanging,
So let's talk about how that works.
Thinking back to where we were before, we're looking side on.
And what we're doing really, is trying to find some values in between where the pixels are.
Right, because if we're resizing the image, or we're moving an image, the NEW locations we've got won't necessarily match up with the previous ones.
So, if this is our image here, these are my 4 actual pixels
Right, nearest neighbor will just sample between these pixels, depending on which one's nearest.
So it'll sort on go along like this and then it'll go like this